and this is a continuation of a lecture
that I just gave on a non Carlson games
as we approach the world championship
match in just a couple weeks in Chennai
India people are really excited about it
how many people think that Anand is
going to prevail and retain his world
championship title couple guys and one
person loudly coughing I guess that did
not oh yeah how many people think it's
going to be a draw the match can't be a
draw that's the whole point of a match
that they can't be drawn and how many
people think that a Magnus Carlsen is
going to win that match alright and
we're also getting the vote of a
grandmaster Ben Feingold here in the
audience st. Louis local we'll also does
a rotation for the grandmasters and
residents and definitely want to check
out all the various videos on YouTube of
the GM's here that come into the
wonderful chess club so as I mentioned
before we had Carlsen at the Chess Club
here in the US for the first time in a
major tournament playing in the same
field cop so he gained a lot of new fans
but we still have some anon fans in the
audience as well obviously 9 is just a
great guy I'm in addition to being a row
champion he also just seems like a
really classy guy and has really
revolutionized the sport in India he's
supposedly as popular as a major sports
star would be in the u.s. in his India
and we would love to see that happen for
chess in America anyway this is one of
his wins against Magnus Carlsen again we
look at the date oh five Magnus Carlsen
at the pitiful rating of 25 48 yes he
doesn't even look at games I guys are
that rating or of course I'm kidding
still a very impressive rating but
Magnus at the time was only 14 years old
right
there you go zit it's important to kind
of keep that in perspective when you're
looking at Carlson games when we have
the Sinquefield Cup in the commentary
booth we were often talking about how
Carlson had a negative record against
this guy and a negative record against
that guy and then you look in the
database and all the games for wedding
he's 12 that's like okay it makes sense
you know that he he wasn't able to have
a positive record against some people so
although despite that I don't think he
has a negative record against very many
people at all in this game Anand playing
white decided that he needed to do
something a little bit drastic in order
to get his advantage rolling
stop a pawn of course but these double
ponds not that easy to utilize kindy to
the drastic moon revolutionising of
addition I'd say thank any qe2 is we've
already solid solid mood centralizing
your king but here a non decided to
really try to transform one advantage
into another advantage he did play d5
yes yeah which at first glance looks
like maybe not the first thing you would
consider because if Knight takes d5 you
play Bishop takes b5 and you you are
giving up the bishop first night but
then you're you're activating your rock
and making it easier to infiltrate into
your opponents to this and so in stay
the Magnus actually took with the pawn
in this position and now after rook to
e5 what do you think white did here yes
you continued with c4 can all these
typical like tactics that we learn when
we're first starting the game pin back
rank mate they're all in the variations
of games by every player doesn't matter
how strong they are we're all using the
same types of tactics
it's just that they see more of them and
they see them a lot earlier but they
still come up so c4 in the search and
with the idea that the trade is of
course impossible because Ricky a mating
or winning winning material rather not
mating but when a material in the
background so instead of black played
King to f8 you could also take on h5
which would be pretty similar to the
game continuation and that way it's to
create this a nice pass pawn
now what do you think white does here
just simple chess
just be for protecting the pond 83
bolstering it 95 work d4 and the reason
I'm showing you this is just to get
warmed up with like a little simple on
and now how does white finish off the
game yeah just rook takes Knight nice so
this is the end of the game because
after work takes d5 c7 and this pawn
conveniently protects this d8 square
which is a nice like nice little tactic
that we see from time to time when we're
dealing with past pawns
now speaking of move order how about if
white switched up the move order and
tried to play c7 first what do you think
about that because last time we talked a
lot about how last class for those of
you weren't there we talked about move
order and how critical it is to tactical
knowledge and so one thing that you know
really helps to go to a teacher to talk
about certain concepts with calculating
even though the main way to get better
at tactics is just to do a lot of them
move order is something you're gonna
want to look at a lot so after Knight
takes even not as good because after
with the e7 checked with the idea of
winning in peace yeah the King can move
to a King e6 or King f6 oh yeah I guess
it doesn't yeah I guess it doesn't
matter that much but then now after rook
takes this is still hanging right so the
move order makes a world of difference
in that case this is a great game that I
want to show the full game of actually
so we can be fair last time we looked at
the game the game I showed you oh that
was also an honest way yeah there's also
non his white the the dragon wearing on
one beautifully that's okay the last
game or fragment that I'll show you is
the one in which Carlsen actually beaten
on in the last time
so that's the freshest thing in the
memory of the two two battling which of
course is a good thing for magnus
carlsen
Surry Lopes a favorite opening of both
players do you think we're gonna see a
lot of Ray Lopez's in this match coming
up in November van
Alex I think we're gonna see a lot of
Roy's I know your openings expert so
yeah both players just loved playing the
Ray Lopez
so we'll probably get see a lot of Miami
I think it's a great opening to first
spectators because it's usually really
rich this is the the chigorin defense
which is one of the main defenses to
bring the night over to a5 and play for
c5 I'm just kind of going over the
opening quickly so why you actually got
a really nice nice little advantage in
this game he played on the c-file
running really to infiltrate here so
Magnus play the kind of unfortunate
looking move a remember Magnus much
lower rated than he is now I thought
somebody gonna have readings in this
game that's weird but oh seven he was
probably like just 20 only like 2,700 or
something well he was the low rate of
player in the game is what I'm trying to
say so Magnus laying the
unpleasant-looking night to a eight but
you know in the closed position it's
usually not the end of the world
so an on playing Queen d2 now it looks
like Magnus Carlsen is trying to trade
some pieces off so now what do you think
Anand it here so I'm showing you this
game and you know probably didn't go
like trade trade trade trade draw like
rook takes EA Queen takes the eight
Queen c2 takes takes and draw probably
want to be the game that I would show
you but anomaly like a really
interesting move in this position
we're seasickness honeying you know I
knew somebody was gonna suggest that
mm-hmm that's how he played well we're
seasick see I mean I see you're just
trying to hammer on f7 but let's take a
look at the actual analysis so okay
we're not forced to take first of all
like you have no threat right so we
could start by playing h6 for one thing
that's one possibility like we play h6
first and then take on c6 and I'm sure
you have like such a major attack
although h6 is hanging in the end
another thing is well what I just what
if I do just take and play like rook c7
or something I guess you probably want
to try like something like Queen d5 but
even that it's after I can actually or
you wanted to take on d6 taking on d6 is
probably a lot better yeah that's a lot
better so I actually don't want to play
work c7 uh yeah I like my h6 move better
and then you go back to f3 and now I can
actually choose you know I don't have to
take this right away I could just play
you want to sacrifice an f7
yeah I guess it's definitely worth
looking at knight of seven king of seven
and queen age six but then it kind of
begs the question if you're going for
this sacrifice like what exactly is your
rook doing here so you want to just
defend with rook AJ yeah I mean it looks
like a good idea
so and if you go back so so what's a
mate if something doesn't work if you
just have to go back oops if you just
have to go back after h6 9 f3 then yeah
then I can just choose I probably just
take care and play King g7 all right and
it doesn't look like you have much of an
enough of nearly enough of attack right
so so you're probably h6 just is good so
what what else can we do here
I'll give you a hint that this is not a
spectacular mouth this movie reminds me
more of King B - lookie lookie one is
not as aggressive as a move in a non
played well it looks like the same
spirit um no he doesn't really want to
trade everything off because he's trying
to attack he's gonna need more pieces in
the board like just like when you were
trying to play Knight f7 and Queen 86
the problem was you you only had one
other piece and what's that yeah what s
1 is the correct move that anon played
well it's what a non-planar I think it's
very inspired because it follows a
principle of not trading when you think
that you have an edge and if you also
think about some of those variations
where you're trying to sacrifice on f7
and they weren't quite bringing it home
if we get a 4 in we have a rook also
participating the accidents gonna be on
stronger although that because working
one I'm not sure where the work is
attacking
oh no nobody he's not but he's not
trying to do a rover he's just trying to
directly attack f7 so we're cat one is a
lot faster because we didn't want to
play f4 and then after take 75 a7 is
gonna be under attack where his working
one it's not as clear where the where
the rook would be participating it would
take more moves to get it into the
action so we're kept on a really classy
move like just not the kind of move you
would think of it's it's the kind of the
quintessential quiet move right so h6
occurred and then what do you think
white did here not but you didn't think
you didn't take 107 you didn't take
enough 7 but he did do something fun
what's that he did play 96 yeah so I
don't want to make it too easy like he
didn't sacrifice on that summon and now
this is this is just a I mean this is
just such a great combination
because you're mixing the quiet with the
violent right you're starting with this
move work everyone and then you're just
like bang and that kind of moves isn't
working when you're trading off pieces
right so let's take a look and see what
happens it takes takes play like say e7
Jack the big problem here is that h6 is
also hanging and like that's getting
white just so much play right
with this night not participated in the
action we already have two pawns and
we're getting another one
yeah it's looking very dangerous what
might you play here for right works e1
and then after so doubt
what's that we can definitely play Queen
b6 at some point now what would you do
now is why it work take c7 and then
after Queen take c7 then your then you
just have a bunch of pawns yeah or just
or just work to c5 c3 is also good and
you're gonna be meeting so multiple wins
here what's hot okay let's look so here
if you seven what can white do that
White's got a pretty good move here
yeah Queen d5 is really four at all
three in Queens e8 we do need this rook
actually because we need to be able to
play off for at some point like if it
wasn't for that like the position
wouldn't be that clear right because
maybe King f6 would be would be adequate
at some point right yeah this is just
brutal so is for instance if Knight b6
air Queens e8 just King f6 now wow maybe
we don't need to work in this situation
these up Queen to f8 and King g5 and
this is where you generally like it stop
and stop analyzing and and trust that
there's gonna be ma yeah f4 is mating by
for us right
no no just Queen G for his mate although
I really would rather meet with a pawn
somehow that yeah that that would be
more fun but it still wouldn't be made
we'd still have to play we still have to
play queen g4 from a although of course
there is one there is one prettier made
in this position I can't believe I
played Queen G for me when I could play
I know I'm such a fish bishop d1 mate is
obviously much stronger
so normally when you get the King to g5
it is important to keep analyzing but
usually you have faith that there's
something there it would really be yeah
unreasonable if there wasn't so King g7
Queen d5 looks crushing so instead after
96 black actually didn't take on his
sexy played King d8 7 instead and now
this loud anon to play will just our
idea with playing or Calphalon just
bring you bri the other piece into the
attack and this is just basic attacking
principle that you want to bring more
pieces into the game it's to see you
executed in a very pretty way which is
counterintuitive a lot of times players
will just start trading off on files
especially in rapid games especially at
the amateur level so seeing him bring
his rook from Cu on the f1 i think is
pretty impressive and it's just very
difficult position obviously for black
so I'm going gonna yeah
you mean in this position after work f1
just don't play eight-six at all
you mean just play like try to play
Queen Oh Queen b6 trying to stop f4 I
think we'd be met by moving the king and
then playing out for anyway and you
still have a really nice attack I get
are you gonna try to play Queen d4 at
some moment or something so if for
instance I were to play King H - you're
gonna play Queen d4 to try to trade
Queens that's definitely a better idea I
mean it's a good idea I don't know if
it's better or worse you know the deep
ones definitely weak I mean maybe we can
just you mean maybe we can just go go
for this and you can't defend it but
Alex's idea also is interesting because
it's kind of a similar idea but he wants
to play Queen c7 with the idea playing
Queen c3 instead hoping that that will
offer more opportunities I think -
problem those similar idea like we just
play a foreign if you play Queen c3
we're also gonna win upon right so
you're not quite getting this
infiltration and in time not to lose
material so yeah it just looks looks
kind of lost he was only 16 give him a
break
so we're Calphalon but these are these
are excellent questions and definitely
very hard to hard to play against Anand
I think that it's friends with an on
right but you big you ever played with a
minute or two min game he's hard to play
against
so yeah this position it is just uh
looking really brutal so you can kind of
move on to the next game in a minute but
I'll show you how it how it ended
but that's definitely a really a really
impressive and instructive game I'm
surprised at how instructive these games
are okay so this one is an ons move what
do you play here
it's from the London Chest classic one
of the great tournaments on the calendar
in December in London and usually our
own Nakamura plays in that as well
in fact I think you've played in
everyone for the beginning and there's
like a satellite yeah so what's the best
move in this position what did I not
play here obviously he's got it you
remember the game or you see it yeah but
I figured you might remember the game as
well because it's only from a couple
years ago not that you wouldn't figure
it out immediately anyway yeah night
eight six is a really good move because
if you just take on d7 immediately
beaches hanging at the end and that's
not much
so instead Anand just played Knight to
h6 chock which forces can't play King h8
because the knight f7 so of course is G
takes eight six and now wait please and
now Queen g4 and we get to play rook
takes d7 with tempo and now after Bishop
to a3 I'm sorry I wanted to have you
guys check that can't check that move
black played Queen to g8 and now we get
to capture the pawn on e6 and actually
took him out in a really long time to
win this and mangoes put up a tremendous
fight because even though the position
is just beautiful for riot there's not
really that much
it's very simplified right and the way
he won was eventually by piling up on
the f6 pawn you actually skipped towards
the position no that's not right
yeah the position where things really
fell apart it was so for 30 moves you
know Magnus was like trying to set up a
fortress and you know get every keep
everything protected and then at this
point after work to c6 with the three
pieces all on the weak f6 pawn this is
when Magnus really collapsed and this
was an interesting moment because both
of them were rated almost exactly the
same at this moment since then Magnus
Carlsen has surpassing on in terms of
rating with all he is two points
lowering and this at this time yeah but
in the last couple years Magnus has been
a number one in the world and an on what
number is none right now for nine Wow
yeah and this is one of and this is so
here we have 28 64 for mine that's more
like it
so yeah this was actually the last game
to played together which certainly does
not mean of a good taste in anons mouth
because you lost the game spoiler this
is over the towel Memorial in Moscow
which he Carl also played in
you were there were you watching the
games lied was it fun what was what was
er was there like a great area for
spectators as well or was it just more
the commentary was in Russian obviously
but you spit you you you speak just as
fluently in Russian as in English but
you can hear you can listen okay yeah
was it difficult for you to to follow
the chess analysis and the language no
even if you haven't been doing it as
much it just you kind of just like fall
right back into it yeah all right so
there's a white tomorrow
where
well actually I do want to kind of look
back in the position just just for a
second at this moment this was a kind of
interesting because at this moment black
played bishop to see a to try to put his
bishop on a stronger square f5b feminist
is kind of hanging out passively so
carlson later said that the move Bishop
was positionally sound but just doesn't
work after a queen a4 so he really saw
almost all the critical variations at
this point it's really rather forcing if
you're gonna follow up logically with
some bishops ei so after rook to c7 f3
which is you know a typical idea in this
type of position to try to play efore
and after Bishop e6 efore did occur now
after it takes on the important so now e
5 is a dangerous idea so because of that
and on took and took and now play Queen
to d7 and in the idea here is it does
make the move e5 less powerful because
we can post up on d5 so that's a reason
actually then an on captured all those
pawns on e4 because if we play e5 here
and you can't play 95 then it's very
strong but now it's less powerful
now
I'll give you a hint that we have seen
this move earlier
in this presentation not sure how much
of a hint that is not people gonna
guesswork to a swan in the record one
what a beautiful move here
I'm not late takes bisshop hello who's
here's a d5 and what's right here okay
so after after after C takes d5 okay so
actually d5 was played in the game and
now after she takes d5 Queen takes d7
Anand in this position was planning to
take with rook yeah because the work is
hanging and then what do you think
Carlson is all our so try to just see it
actually it's you see it from this try
to calculate different this to their
chance
because Magnus thought that nod just
made a simple miscalculation and that
variation to try to figure out what it
was that Magnus missed I mean sorry that
an I missed
what did he miss why is it so good for
Wyatt after takes on d5 Queen d7 rook d7
what's so well yeah sure
that would be good you can't see but you
feel like there's something going on
there with the bishop yeah I'll try to
try to make something work that's
forcing because there is a forcing line
here that Magnus used to good effect in
fact this was a bit of an embarrassing
the beeper on because he lost not I
think he resigned not too many moves
after this
you know always looking at all the
captures and forcing moves is really
important whether you're just starting
out or you becoming advanced buyers or
whether you're the very best players in
the world obviously very rare for
players of that level to miss me miss
like simpler tactical variations but it
certainly happens that's what makes it
watching these matches really
interesting that usually you'll see
pretty flawless tactical chests but
there can be some kind of lightning ball
at some point of the match or somebody
just completely misses something which
it doesn't happen with computers
so any ideas here for Wyatt after takes
on d5 Queen takes t7 work takes t7 got
on the board and has an idea so your sir
you were talking about something on that
diagonal yes I mean that makes a lot of
sense I think that's why I got what a
lot of people would be looking at in
this position like certain tactics
trying to take advantage of the back
rank and the pins like trying to trying
to make something like takes md5 work
Knight takes d5 Knight takes d5 55 rook
t1 but it doesn't quite work because we
can just play work the DA and then after
a bishop deef what's that go ahead what
are you saying so instead of instead of
playing takes on d5 here you just want
to play so Knight takes bishop and then
after F takes c6 and then say we play
something like rook to e7 so use 1.96
take c6 Bishop h3 and then if rookie
Simon
but you haven't taken you haven't you
take you haven't taken on defy that well
yeah just take on d5 exactly so you were
you were exactly exactly right so 90 86
is the brilliant move that was was
missed by andand much earlier in the
variation I'm sure like once this has
started to happen he realized but it was
too late
so it it's very counterintuitive because
you see the bishop being so strong in
this diagonal all right
and I think that's why it's kind of hard
to see because you're looking for things
like takes on d5 and then after Knight
takes d5 Knight d5 Bishop d5 something
like rook to d1 looks pretty promising
at first glance right
right because now if we if we hit her
play rook da Bishop d5 rook d5 or 3545
it's mating right so we after each takes
d5 9595 Bishop d5 worked you on we do
here thought we had something like with
maybe we have to try taking with the
bishop here
so that after work did you on still
looks good why don't I miss hair maybe
after takes md5 we just play g5 just
looks horrible after takes any sex all
right yeah we can play a bit about five
maybe this is it's probably a little bit
hard probably a little bit more
difficult for white than the game yeah
what am I missing you think do you think
it's just you think it's just that this
variation is a little a little harder
for right I mean it still clearly good
for Wyatt but there's no win yeah this
one's immediately where this is just an
advantage for riot because I mean it
doesn't really lead to anything clear
you know after d6 we can just you just
move the rock and now actually the pawns
in danger so instead it's just like it's
some kind of advantage for riot where as
I'll be after after Knight takes c6 one
take takes Bishop h3 everything's really
falling apart now if we're anywhere
comes to e7 if this one comes and just
takes on d5
it's just the pin and the attack on e6
is crushing and it's work to e8
same thing taking on d5 it's just
crushing because of all these attacks so
instead a non displayed King to hae but
now Carlsen instead of taking on e6
started with E 5 and then after Bishop
takes c6 the problem is he's also going
to lose d5 it's gonna be impossible to
defend everything works e7 preventing
Knight to e7 and now this nice move
Bishop to d7 blocking the future defense
of d4 and pushing forward with Issei
and it's just resigning now so
interestingly actually the material is
still evil here but of course it's just
totally crushing for Wyatt I mean I
guess yeah the only thing to attempt
here would be something like Knight to
e7 right but you can't even move the
knight to such an aggressive square you
can you can only play Knight to d5 but
we could even play rook to b7 there and
it's just hard hard for you to move the
knight anywhere even f6 is is a under
attack so a really impressive game from
Carlsen and pretty poor first
performance for a non hopefully the
match will not go like that actually I
mean I'm personally rooting for Carlsen
because I think it's gonna be really
good for chess if he wins but I hope the
match will be very interesting as well
anyway I hope you guys enjoy these this
kind of review of the anon Carlsen games
I kind of tried to pick out some of the
most interesting battles it interests me
that in both that game I showed you
where Anand had that better endgame and
he played d5 and then took on d5 and
started assuring the C pawn forward that
a key move was d5 and then also in this
game a key move was d5 breaking open all
the lines and allowing white to play
Queen takes d7 and find this nice Knight
takes c6 e 6 move with just 1
immediately so in both cases the key
move being d5 and also lots of
interesting tactics in their games